what's your process I've never written a
song I play guitar I often have a guitar
with me I play guitar all the time I
love it I'm always playing other
people's music I've never tried to write
a song and I I think I have a block
against it I don't think I could be
emotionally vulnerable and write a song
If I wrote a song it would be there's a
lot of people that aren't emotionally
vulnerable and in their song that's true
like a Chumbawamba
knocked down yeah I mean like I don't I
don't I guess that has vulnerability in
it no now that I think about it like do
you think WAP has a lot of vulnerability
uh like you could have like a hype
Anthem like maybe that's more of your
maybe that's more like a bragging yeah
I'm all that yeah no one wants to
probably hear me open up about my inner
hurt no I mean maybe
no they don't have any you know oh my
God you know what I also saw I mean I
know this has probably been commented on
a lot but we went and saw we went over
and saw Megan thee stallion yeah perform
and there's a woman doing sign language
oh yeah I'm sure they all notice this
and it's been talked about in their
videos but I was in the crowd watching
this woman she's singing lyrics yeah
she's singing the lyrics and it is
Hardcore and this woman who looks like
she would you know break into a
telephone on PBS say if you'd like to
get your tote bag the number is one
three two three 44. This Woman's there
and she's
acting out with her hands yeah the most
graphic stuff with no expression on her
face oh no no some of them are really
like stoked though like they have like
their own performance style right that's
a whole other thing they might dance
along I've seen those those are fun yeah
yeah yeah especially at Rapids they're
amazing because they know all the stuff
beforehand and they get really into it
right I mean you could go down in
YouTube rabbit hole of sign language
interpreters I was blown away by that I
mean I couldn't I had a hard time paying
attention to making these stallion I
just because I my eyes were riveted on
this woman I was just amazed by and what
she was her dead band like yeah I mean
she wasn't exactly dead pen but also she
also looked like I might have to leave
soon to close the library
you know it's
but I don't know how you do you
consciously sit down to write a song or
does something come to you yeah I feel
feel like very uh when I was younger I
feel like I I was like waiting for the
spirit
um to possess me or something but now I
feel like it's more of like a faucet you
know like I feel like I I put myself in
an environment that I know is is going
to be conducive to like writing like I
go into like a forest or something like
a like a cottage in the woods and write
songs and you write on the guitar I do
usually write on the guitar for the last
record I I kind of tried to like find
new ways to um push myself out of my
comfort zone and ride on piano or you
know sometimes I actually just draw like
on a midi Board of like because I don't
have like a very strong Theory knowledge
so if I could like hear the chord I want
it's actually really helpful you can
like drag a bar of like a do you know
what midi is I don't uh it's it's just
like a like I don't know like you can
like drag a note sort of like on a graph
and like it'll make a sound is it a
program
um
can you please explain that yeah it's a
language yeah so it's like a computer
language that allows you to write music
you can transpose every note or chord
via this midi language and it'll spit
out the note and you can make chords and
it's the way all modern music is now
mostly made you know via computers oh so
you could say if if you knew okay it's
it's a g but it's not a g I want it to
have something I want it to have a
slightly different you could on midi
maybe play with the G and get a g
suspended seven right right ninth yeah
without knowing that that's what you're
getting exactly okay that's cool yeah
yeah so you can like have the G on the
bass and then like with another note
like drag it until it makes the sound
you're like oh it's that chord and that
sometimes that would take me a much
longer time to find on the guitar with
my personal knowledge do you think that
it might learning theory might actually
get in the way of your creative process
ever yeah I mean I started taking some
lessons I mean I hear that uh like but
in in my experience like even just like
learning a very very small amount of
theory has been really help helpful for
me because you're just like oh I can't
believe I got this far without like
knowing what makes certain songs I'm
just curious because I've never had any
of that and I'm I'm now even at this
stage life thinking I think I need a
teacher now I mean yeah you know it's
been years and years and years of me
having people kind of show me songs I
want to play or riffs I want to play and
so I I think I have a jukebox in my when
I pick up a Guitar there's a lot of
songs I can play yeah but I don't know
what how the hell it all works right
right and maybe knowing how it worked
would be fun for me at this stage I
think so and I think that like even if
you learn too much in a way that
inhibits you there's always ways to like
kind of unlearn it like I found that I
took you know some more guitar lessons
and found that was helpful and then when
it was no longer helpful then you can
just like put a capo on or change the
tuning and then you just you don't know
any anymore what you're doing so I feel
like there are weird tricks to like get
to protect yourself from from that
ruining something but for me I found it
to be really helpful and I feel like
when you listen to music I mean there's
a way to interact with music that's like
oh that's like hunting or that's
interesting or then you know or that's
just like a minor third you know I feel
like you're all like chasing they're
just like different ways to like Chase a
feeling or something all I ever heard
when I was first playing guitar some
some guy told me minor chords are the
ones that make girls fall in love
and I was like really and then sure
enough you play an A Minor and you're
like well I did and nothing happened no
one was interested but you could kind of
see like oh I see how what minor chords
yeah yeah you know e is like yeah yeah
but E minor he's kind of dreamy
well I basically just tricked you into
giving me guitar advice well this has
been a joy it's been an absolute Joy
thank you for giving me street cred with
my daughter oh I'm so Nev I'm gonna Lord
this over her and she actually last
night because I had read your book and
uh had been listening a lot to your
music and then she called me last night
to just make sure that I didn't screw
things up she sounds so cool I'm very
she's I feel very indented to her she's
very cool but I'm indebted to her for uh
for bringing me to Coachella so that uh
I got to see you do your thing and I
love that you came in and talked to me
this is amazing thank you for having me
thank you all well don't thank them
find midi which was incredible yeah but
he's basically he's been watching my own
like Miss Pac-Man just like melting down
mini it's kind of a free
and we gotta write that song what is it
yes
I'm telling you that's going to be huge